we're now going to think about
ionization energy Trends what's
ionization energy it's the energy
required to remove the highest energy
electron from an atom and to think about
this let's look at some data so right
over here is ionization energy plotted
against atomic number for elements in
the periodic table of elements so first
we can look Group by group so for
example if we look at group one that's
the First Column the leftmost column in
the periodic table of elements starting
with hydrogen here you can see that as
we go down that column it looks like
generally speaking our ionization energy
is decreasing for group two we see a
similar pattern as we go down that
second column our ionization energy
generally speaking it looks like there's
a few slight anomalies here it looks
like it's decreasing so as you go down a
group The data seems to imply that
ionization energy decreases it takes
less and less energy to remove that
highest energy electron now let's look
at the periods so remember the periods
are the rows in the periodic table so if
we look at that second row in the
periodic table as we go from left to
right it looks like generally speaking
ionization energy is increasing it
becomes harder and harder to remove that
highest energy electron now there are
some anomalies here it looks like it
briefly decreases then it increases
briefly decreases but the general trend
is as you go from left to right along
that period energy is
increasing we see the same thing in
Period 3 once again there are some
anomalies here but the trend seems to
generally hold we could also look at
period 4 and so on and so forth so if we
think about ionization energy energy
what we saw is as we go down a group
right over here it becomes easier and
easier to remove that highest energy
electron or another way to think about
it is ionization energy
decreases if you go from left to right
along a period right over here we saw
from the data that ionization energy
increases now let's think about why this
is well if you look at this trend along
or get an intuition for why this is if
you look at this trend along a group
over here we already said that you're
going to have the same number of veence
electrons but those veence electrons are
further and further out they're at
higher and higher energy shells and so
you have a lot more shielding from all
of those core electrons so that causes
some interference we've already seen
that as you go down a group your atomic
radius increases so you're also going to
have have less of that effective nuclear
force which is essentially how much the
force is between when you consider the
the nucleus when you consider the
shielding from the electrons in between
and when you think about the distance of
those outer electrons and so it makes
sense that it's easier and easier to
remove the highest energy electron from
say cesium because it's further out
there there's more electrons shielding
it from that from that nucleus even
though there's a lot of there's a lot of
protons in that nucleus than say in the
case of hydrogen now as you go from left
to right along a period we already
talked about the fact that you're adding
electrons but you're either backfilling
into a lower energy shell or you're
adding at that same outer veence shell
but as you're doing so as you're going
from left to right you have more and
more protons so those protons as you had
more and more you're going to have a
stronger positive charge it's going to
pull more and more on those outer
electrons and remember you have the same
number of core electrons because you're
just adding to the outer shells right
over here and so it's going to pull
harder and harder on them and bring them
closer and closer and we saw that Atomic
radi decreases as you go from left to
right and so it makes sense that
ionization energy increases it's going
to be harder and harder to pull off that
highest energy electron from say bromine
than it would be from say pottassium